cinquante mille numéros de téléphone si
b depuis 2016 dont l'un de ceux
d'emmanuel maquereau en 2019
voici selon un consortium de médias
l'ampleur du scandale d'espionnage qui a
provoqué cette semaine de vives tensions
entre le maroc et la france
une cyber surveillance sans précédent
réalisé grâce au logiciel pegasus pour
le compte des services de sécurité
marocains
le gouvernement français a immédiatement
annoncé vouloir faire la lumière sur ces
allégations
le parquet de paris a donc ouvert une
enquête ces faits sont extrêmement
choquant des faits qui s'ils sont avérés
sont extrêmement graves il va y avoir
évidemment des enquêtes des
éclaircissements demandés parmi les
cibles supposé 14 membres du
gouvernement français de l'époque
parmi eux edouard philippe christophe
castaner nicole belloubet ou encore jean
yves le drian
mais aussi des parlementaires des
avocats et des journalistes qui aurait
été espionnée par le maroc
face à ces accusations de nombreux
hommes politiques se disent inquiets
c'est l'intrusion dans nos téléphones
portables par par une dispositif qui est
un dispositif on ne sait pas par qui les
contrôle et comment à quoi ça sert c'est
terrible c'est aussi le signe de la
faiblesse de nos outils de sécurité de
protection des plus hauts dirigeants
français donc il faudra en tirer toutes
les conséquences de son côté le maroc a
catégoriquement démenti le recours aux
logiciels pegasus créée par l'entreprise
israélienne et des sceaux pegasus une
fois introduits dans les smartphones est
capable de récolter des données privées
comme les messages ou les photos il peut
aussi prendre le contrôle du micro et de
la caméra de l'appareil ciblées le
groupe est né sous insiste sur l'absence
de lien entre son logiciel et les
services du gouvernement israélien nso
est une entreprise privée n'est pas une
porte dérobée pour les services de
renseignements israéliens
face au scandale les dirigeants de
l'état hébreu ont annoncé la création
d'une commission interministérielle
elle celle ci comprendra notamment des
diplomates des représentants du mossad
et des renseignements militaires qui
seront chargés d'étudier d'éventuelles
dérives liées à ce logiciel
le ministre israélien de la défense
assure que ce programme ne peut être
vendus qu'à des fins de lutte contre le
terrorisme
nous n'approuvons l'exportation de
produits cybernétique qu'au gouvernement
et uniquement pour un usage légal afin
de prévenir le crime et le terrorisme
les pays qui achètent ces systèmes
doivent adhérer aux conditions
d'utilisation
après ces révélations l'algérie a aussi
fait part de ses préoccupations et a
annoncé l'ouverture d'une enquête
elle accuse son voisin d'avoir recouru à
pegasus pour surveiller certains de ses
dirigeants et de ses citoyens
le maroc a attaqué en diffamation les
médias l'origine du scandale
le ministre israélien des affaires
étrangères a de son côté annoncé une
rencontre avec le roi du maroc à la fin
du mois de juillet